[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport sur TV 78 l'émission ne
surtout pas manqué si vous êtes un
amoureux de sport local aujourd'hui
comme toujours il y aura des analyses
techniques des décryptages et surtout
une dose de bonne humeur pour
m'accompagner nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous sur ce plateau et croyez moi ils
sont en pleine forme présentation de
cette magnifique équipe on commence à ma
droite musique c'est l'un des piliers de
cette émission c'est un pistard de
niveau international et il était
champion du monde de cyclisme sur piste
Masters il est spécialiste cyclisme mais
il s'y connaît vraiment dans tous les
sports Mesdames et Messieurs le
capitaine viennent du Jarrier est avec
nous bonsoir je m'y connais dans tous
les soirs je suis passionné par le sport
je m'y connais pas dans tous les sports
non plus il faut pas pousser oui
merci
quand même en cyclisme un petit peu un
petit peu et d'ailleurs on a une course
en ce moment une course une course bah
il y a une des classiques
bien sûr pas sur le plateau autour des
studios ouais je précise on passe de
l'autre côté musique c'est lui aussi une
légende vivante il ne lâche jamais rien
dans l'arène du si on parlait sport il
est préparé il est affûté comme jamais
tel un estate romain notre gladiateur
Pierre Chevalier est avec nous salut
Michael salut les amis et vous nous
venez de Versailles oui pas très très
loin de du plateau traverser les plaines
potes cheval Glide glaive affûté comme
jamais comme une dague on voit que vous
êtes en pleine forme c'est parfait en
pleine forme au pluriel en pleine forme
je vous retiens on passe de l'autre côté
musique c'est un petit nouveau mais il
devient de plus en plus grand il est au
nord déjà sa cinquième sélection cette
émission il est responsable sponsoring
chez Orange en Île-de-France il adore le
sport il est amoureux du sport mesdames
et messieurs Philippe voilà que nous
fait l'honneur de venir dans cette
émission pendant une heure bonjour à
tous toujours un plaisir et à fond les
Yvelines parce que voilà encore ce
weekend
j'avais les Yvelines avec moi au Stade
de France et donc ça fait plaisir tout
le temps les Yvelines en fait je crois
que je vais déménager dans les Yvelines
un beau département merci on termine de
l'autre côté musique c'est également une
star mondiale des milliers de fans
l'adules à travers le monde il est une
icône du sport c'est coup de gueule son
meetics ces analyses sont à chaque fois
pertinentes coach Jean Miss Aix
entraîneur de plaisir est avec nous
pendant une heure bonne soirée calme
bonsoir les amis tout va bien comment
allez-vous
petit problème au dos mais sinon ça va
un problème au dos oui oui peut-être les
l'héritage du rugby on fait du vilain
vieux comme ça
ça commence à payer mais pas du bon côté
de ce midi
je tenais à remercier d'ailleurs
pour l'invitation alors avant de passer
au programme de l'émission à parler de
natation ce dimanche 19 mars l'ambiance
était au rendez-vous à la piscine le
dôme à Saint-Germain-en-Laye pour la
première fois depuis 2019
l'Île-de-France a accueilli un grand
meeting de natation le Giant open avec
plusieurs têtes d'affiches françaises
les tribunes étaient remplies avec
plusieurs centaines de personnes dans
les tribunes on écoute les réactions
vous voulez voir tous les nageurs que
j'aimais et comme je suis nageur je
voulais peut-être essayer d'améliorer ma
technique en fonction de comment il nage
parce qu'on habite pas très loin de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'était l'occasion
de pouvoir voir des athlètes qu'on verra
peut-être pas aux JO et tout simplement
bah pour pouvoir des performances
simplement hors norme et mondial et
c'est vraiment je pense que ça revenait
d'avoir ça aussi près de reproche de
chez moi
alors ce nouveau format de compétition a
d'ailleurs été très bien accueilli par
les nageurs les deux têtes d'affiches
françaises Maxime Grousset qui a
remporté le 100 mètres nage libre en 48
50 ou encore charlotte Bonnet nouvelle
record woman sur le 100m brasse on les
écoute une super ambiance là pour ma
finale tout le monde m'a super bien
encouragé je l'ai senti
belle piscine aussi bien habillée le bon
organisation sur les finales donc voilà
rien à dire c'était super c'est la
première fois que je venais ici à
Saint-Germain
[Musique]
donc vraiment une très très bonne
ambiance beaucoup de publics qui nous
encourage et qui sont à fond derrière
nous l'équipe de France donc ça fait
plaisir vu la réussite de cet événement
la piscine de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
pouvait-elle prétendre à accueillir les
JO de 2024 quand on voit cet événement à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye oui non ou voter
non pour vous gens non pour vous pierre
vous êtes tous une à lime non vous êtes
un peu partagé Philippe alors pourquoi
on va commencer par vous ouais parce que
quand on parle des Jeux Olympiques il y
a aussi il y a plusieurs il y a
plusieurs piscines pour les Jeux
Olympiques donc c'est un peu je veux
dire voilà il y a le à côté du stade de
France il y a voilà en Seine-Saint-Denis
juste à côté du stade de France ça sera
pour les épreuves plongeon water-polo et
natation artistique et il y aura aussi
Paris dépenses Arena les épreuves de
vitesse mais bon c'est c'est bien je
veux dire bon il y a pas tout le gratin
il y a tout le gratin bien sûr français
bon il manque le la star
de la star des voilà qui est Léon
marchand donc voilà qui est vraiment la
star quand on regarde toutes les comment
je veux dire les les tous les gagnants
il y avait il y avait beaucoup de
Français mais je pense que ça a été ça a
été comme une réussite et c'est
important et puis le dôme de
Saint-Quentin
de Saint- pardon avec une piscine
olympique et trois autres bassin je
pense que ce que c'est bien c'est une
c'est bien pour promouvoir la natation
donc pour vous c'est bien pour
promouvoir mais peut-être pas assez pour
les Jeux Olympiques assez pour les pas
assez pour les Jeux Olympiques et bon
moi je pense que ça aurait été
préférable de que la natation se passe
au même endroit on va en ce moment même
à la piscine qui sera juste à côté du
stade de France à Saint-Denis qui va
accueillir du coup les les épreuves de
plongeon water-polo natation artistique
le coup un 164 millions d'euros il y a
du Jarrier qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
où est-ce que il y aurait pu avoir des
des compétitions de ce type à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye
compétition olympique bien sûr alors
le bassin est un bassin olympique
d'accord mais ensuite il y a toute une
structure autour c'est à dire que il
faut un bassin d'échauffement il faut
des des infrastructures et puis des
tribunes tout à fait là quand on voit il
y a 5 rangées de 5 rangées de
spectateurs je suis désolé sur des JO la
piscine ça doit être 15 entre 15 10 et
20 000 personnes
alors il y aura sur la piscine de
Saint-Denis justement j'ai regardé les
chiffres 5000 places pour les jeux et
2500 après les Jeux donc qui
réadapteront mais 5000 passes en tout
cas pour les jeux encore une fois c'est
sous-dimensionné par rapport à la
capacité
d'accueil des Jeux Olympiques en France
je suis désolé ils auraient pu faire des
des enceintes 5000 places ou comment
s'appelle à l'urna non non pour le pour
la piscine qui est à côté parce que la u
Arena je suis bête donc du coup je
comprends pourquoi est-ce que est-ce que
cette piscine de Saint-Denis ne va pas
accueillir les épreuves de vitesse pour
les épreuves de vitesse il faut entre
15000 et 20000 et 20000 spectateurs il
faut une capacité bien bien supérieure
et je suis et donc ce n'était pas
possible de le faire de le faire sur
Saint-Denis c'est les JO pour pouvoir
contenter le maximum de personnes je ne
vais pas dire tout le monde pour pouvoir
contenter Maxime de personnes il faut il
faut des grosses capacités et pour moi
entre 15 et 20 000 personnes je pense
que c'est un minimum justement l'image
de ces futurs jeux olympiques dans
l'Arena de de
Paris défense
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez il faut
surtout voir en y réfléchir en termes de
cahier des charges là on a effectivement
un complexe qui se construit au pied du
Stade de France donc c'est une un des
futurs futurs pôles du sport olympique
en 2024 pour Paris et puis là on a une
on a une un lieu existant parce que ça
aussi les cahiers des charges quand
Paris a dû proposer sa candidature pour
2024 il y avait tous les sites qui
existaient il y avait tous les sites à
produire un produit à construire là on a
on a ainsi comme Saint-Germain qui a une
piscine olympique qui existe et qui
démarre finalement un peu tard sur un je
dirais sur un sur un événement de
séduction de séduction et de préparation
jusqu'au jusqu'au Jo 2024 en essayant
d'attirer le plus grand nombre de le
plus grand nombre de spectateurs et
surtout en fait de tête d'affiches donc
là on en a vu deux il y avait je crois
Alain Bernard qui qui
donnait son image pour pouvoir justement
communiquer autour de cette de
manifestation et c'est au final un peu
difficile d'imaginer que le site
existant sans aucun travaux ou sans
aucune sans aucun aménagement soit soit
taillée pour accueillir le la planète
entière la planète entière pour les JO
2024 donc si ils ont construit un
événement un
bâtiment au pied du Stade de France
c'est qu'à priori il manquait pour les
pour les épreuves de de plongeon de
natation synchronisée notamment et que
là au moins on se met petit à petit à un
peu plus d'un an de l'événement dans
dans l'événement et puis on teste un
petit peu le la pétanque des yvelinois
puisque c'est à Saint-Germain à la
tenue de l'événement il y a déjà pas mal
de sports qui vont avoir lieu dans les
Yvelines il fallait quand même en donner
un petit peu à tout le monde à
l'Île-de-France je parle surtout de
l'Île-de-France on sait qu'on a des
épreuves
délocaliser à Marseille ou ailleurs pour
la voile notamment et que
c'est quand même c'est quand même Paris
2024 et donc il faut il faut en donner à
tout le monde là c'est une bonne
occasion de se tester et de tester la
pétanque des des franciliens et des
yvelinois pour les pour les JO mais de
là à dire que ils avaient déjà les
infrastructures pour accueillir a priori
non et le je dirais que les chantiers
actuels le prouve genre qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez vous avez entendu sur sur
la question
tout a été dit c'est vrai et je dis
simplement juste rajouter que si
Saint-Germain aurait fait l'affaire ils
auraient pas construit
une piscine au pied du Stade de France
et ils ont pris Saint-Germain donc j'ai
pas les tenants ils aboutissants le
pourquoi du comment il y a certainement
les réseaux parce que est-ce que ça
aurait pu être à Saint-Germain il serait
pu sauf que
ça aurait pu gérer non puisque sinon on
aurait pas mis ça à 62 millions d'euros
pour construire
voilà alors 174
peut-être
ça mais donc donc pour moi on aurait
pris Saint-Germain si Saint-Germain
avait fait l'affaire là on a fait cette
cette organisation qui est une réussite
d'après le témoignage des nageurs
présente ce jour là c'était une
peut-être une petite répétition pour un
petit peu comment ça peut une autre
compétitions
enfin championnat d'Europe et on sera
prêt pour les Jeux olympiques mais sinon
sur le le site lui-même s'il avait fait
l'affaire on aurait pas construit à la
défa à Saint-Denis ça fait très
longtemps que la natation dit qu'il
manque d'un vrai site pour pouvoir
accueillir des des grands championnats
vraiment Montpellier Montpellier c'est
Montpellier
mais c'est pas des c'est il y a pas il y
a pas les infrastructures avec tribune
etc pour pouvoir accueillir des des gros
gros
c'était énorme mais bon mais pour
l'appareil défense Arena ça sera du coup
ce sera du temporaire de l'éphémère
adapté effectivement alors on continuera
à parler des Jeux olympiques de 2024 un
peu plus tard dans l'émission alors nous
allons maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler du tennis et de la chute au
classement ATP de livinois Arthur
rinderknech nous parlerons aussi du FC
Versailles qui devrait monter en Ligue 2
si tout se passe bien d'ici la fin de la
saison mais le club devra se trouver un
autre stade pour l'année prochaine en
Ligue 2 mais avant de parler de ces
thématique on va parler de football
américain
[Musique]
alors on va parler dans cette thématique
des Templiers d'Élancourt dans le
championnat de deuxième division casque
d'or les Templiers d'Élancourt n'y
arrivent toujours pas les élans courtois
se sont inclinés à domicile contre les
Léopards de Rouen le week-end du 25 mars
ils se sont inclinés 43 à 6 au
classement les 50 humains sont toujours
dernier avec 0 match gagné en 5 journées
on écoute ce qu'ils avaient dit sur
notre plateau avant que la saison ne
commence on a un deuxième division
depuis 2017 comme vous l'avez bien vu
bah il y a un certain laps de temps de
formation moi qui ai joué à l'époque
dans les dans dans les équipes seniors
et dans les hautes équipes de
première division et autres là on est
sur une phase de construction on est sur
une phase de recrutrition en fait qui
prend son temps et elle est pérenne elle
est pérenne puisqu'on arrive à rester
justement dans cette deuxième division
on accède régulièrement aux phase de
playoff et je pense que cet objectif
doit être en continu l'accession playoff
et après viser toujours plus haut
l'année dernière c'est ce qui nous est
arrivé on nous fait un bon parcours
alors la question sur cette thématique
faut-il s'inquiéter pour les Templiers
d'Élancourt oui pour vous Yann oui pour
vos pierres oui pour vous Jean et ah oui
d'accord c'est le
versé je m'inquiète alors Jean pourquoi
il faut s'inquiéter alors vous êtes tous
unanime il faut s'inquiéter pour les
Templiers d'Élancourt genre c'est
tellement évident il faisait parce qu'il
gagne pas il gagne pas son dernier donc
là on vient d'écouter l'objectif ben
c'était de construire de se mettre
donner le temps de construire mais de
construire en restant en deuxième
division là ça sent ça sent plus la
descente que que l'objectif d'une montée
et son deuxième division depuis 2017 je
le rappelle oui mais non mais sauf que
là sauf que là ils sont pas bien bon les
Léopards qui prennent 40 points c'est
pas c'est pas ils ont pas perdu la
dernière seconde c'est pas donc c'est à
mon avis c'est c'est dans la dans leur
construction
et je crois que peut-être que le niveau
de leur construction et sportivement il
est trop élevé peut-être que pour se
reconstruire peut-être qu'il
redescendent d'un cran pour reconstruire
quelque chose de solide et remonter et
avec les lampes essayer de de dorer leur
blason mais là sportivement on peut pas
dire qu'une équipe qui est classée
dernière la saison est va vite au front
l'Américain donc ils vont en janvier ça
va très vite et ils vont pas c'est pas
comme au football par exemple où il y a
énormément de journées le manque de
match et que ça change très vite parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de matchs pour Ben
pour passer pour passer des des au
classement pour être regardé ou monter
là ils ont peu de rencontres ça va être
très compliqué pour à peu près la moitié
du championnat et voilà donc ça va être
très compliqué quand on est dernier à
moitié championnat
c'est ça va être juste aller chercher
déjà des places à qualificatives là donc
pour moi je suis un petit peu pessimiste
pour pour leur sort Philippe moi je
m'inquiète ok pour le pour les résultats
sportifs et ce que je m'inquiète surtout
c'est que en dessous les U20 la dernière
rencontre ils ont déclaré forfait pour
manque d'effectif ils avaient eu aussi
un problème médical
les grands aussi les seniors ont eu ce
problème là sur un match le médecin est
arrivé je crois trop tard et du coup là
le match a été compté comme perdu
la dernière fois pour manque d'effectif
les U17 les U17 perdent aussi
régulièrement c'est quand même le
dessous quand même et pour le club
peut-être parce que bon en regardant les
réseaux sociaux ils se disent que il y a
une guéguerre dans le club depuis deux
ou trois ans qui se dit donc il y a
quand même quelque chose quand même au
niveau au niveau du club quand même donc
faut quand même se tracasser parce que
si derrière ça suit pas
c'est ceux qui sont juste derrière les
seniors et c'est l'avenir il y en a pas
il dit que la forfait en plus manque
d'effectif aussi c'est surtout ça c'est
même pas un manque de commande de
commande de niveau de résultats c'est
manque d'effectif je pense que c'est là
qu'il faut se casser parce que je pense
que les joueurs partent ailleurs ou
alors ils récupèrent pas assez de
joueurs pourtant ils ont quand même
récupéré des joueurs cette année ils ont
quand même des récupérer un Américain
enfin je veux dire c'était quand même
mais là c'est inquiétant quand même
c'est c'est la saison est courte comme
on disait tout à l'heure vous les voyez
descendre
j'espère pas mais
c'est c'est pas top c'est pas top c'est
un peu notre équipe fétiche sur ce
plateau on en parle depuis depuis des
années et on en parle souvent parce que
les Templiers parce que c'est l'un des
clubs phares du secteur de des Yvelines
qui a été très haut en Coupe d'Europe
au niveau européen qui est un sport qui
est difficile finalement qui est
difficile à faire exister en France on
leur a ça ça aussi on en a beaucoup
disserté par rapport par rapport aux
États-Unis à l'ombre des États-Unis sur
le le football américain et on en parle
très souvent parce que parce que c'est
une justement comme le challenge et le
challenge est difficile de faire exister
le football américain en France on en
parle très souvent on avait aussi ici
même un chroniqueur qui était qui était
un des entraîneurs de du foot US il y a
quelques années
au Japon voilà et qui nous parlait très
régulièrement des des Templiers et et on
a maintenant on a on a une on a on a un
œil on a un œil quand même assez
bienveillant quand même sur cette équipe
malgré malgré des envies et des
objectifs affichés en chaque début de
saison à chaque début de saison en
disant que il s'est l'objectif c'est la
montée ou l'objectif c'est laquelle il
faut appeler et puis là depuis un an
samedi
et en fait le le contenu est pas donc il
y a des paillettes qui nous sont qui que
sont promises chaque année et puis
finalement le compte n'y est pas donc
c'est on peut je suis déçu et
effectivement
particulièrement sur cette saison là un
peu inquiet parce que ou carrément
inquiet parce que parce qu'on est là
pour le coup de gueule en comptable et
sportif il est quand même très
préoccupant avec avec avec la course à
la première victoire net là en plus la
dernière défaite comme dit jeannotype
sur une interception à la dernière
seconde quand même 43 à 6 bon voilà ok
oui c'est inquiétant c'est inquiétant et
et là ce qu'il faudrait trouver c'est
justement les les raisons et les
recettes qui n'y sont pas
sur le bout des doigts mais dangereux de
voir ces résultats là possible descente
mais en tout cas pour attirer les
sponsors ça a été un peu plus difficile
et on sait que le football américain
c'est pas forcément le sport le plus
visible en France donc ils ont besoin
d'avoir des résultats pour pouvoir vivre
en fait finalement visibilité
un sport qui je pense doit coûter un peu
cher parce que l'équipement c'est pas la
même chose que pour le footing ou même
pour le rugby on est quand même on est
quand même sur sur d'autres d'autres
sphères des d'équipements et puis et
puis une complexité je pense que si il
manque de j'ai la chance de faire la
chance on regarde super beau on regarde
le foot US maintenant régulièrement sur
sur nos chaînes
on entend parler de équipe d'attaque
équipe de défense les équipes spéciales
etc
ça fait donc oui il faut du monde et
pour un sport qui en France n'est ne pas
être très peu très peu médiatisé avec en
plus une grosse problématique et là elle
est générale c'est que aujourd'hui quel
que soit les quel que soit le sport on a
de plus en plus de mal à faire faire de
la compétition aux gens je pense que
dans le rugby vous le vivez aussi dans
le foot etc dans tous les voilà les gens
veulent faire du loisir mais faire de la
compétition et l'investissement lié à la
compétition c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué les gens sont consommateurs
les gens sont consommateurs et donc et
puis après
rendre aujourd'hui moi je j'ai la j'ai
une c'est à dire que j'ai eu une
carrière sportive amateur mais qui m'a
été donné par le biais du bénévolat qui
est permis enfin qui qui était fait
pendant des années par par beaucoup de
gens aujourd'hui
dès qu'on me demande dès qu'il y a une
organisation que ça fait dans le club de
mes enfants ou dans d'autres cadres je
propose mes services pour rendre ce qui
m'a été donné à une époque et ça je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
gens qui l'ont oublié c'est à dire que
oui en effet on a pu faire des choses où
on peut faire des choses parce qu'il y a
des bénévoles mais si
les rôles ne sont pas inversés à
certains moments et bien les les
épreuves et les clubs ne sont plus
justement les bénévoles on en parlera un
peu plus tard dans l'émission je tiens à
dire que vous n'aviez pas grand chose à
dire il y a du Jarrier en fait
les Templiers et attendront de remporter
en tout cas leur première victoire de la
saison le 15 avril chez les dragons de
Paris on leur souhaite évidemment de
rebondir de rebondir alors on va
maintenant parler de tennis les
mauvaises performances s'enchaînent pour
le tennisman Yvelines wa de 27 ans
Arthur rinderknech en 2023 il a un bilan
de deux victoires dont une en Coupe
Davis est si défaites dont une en Coupe
Davis les désormais
72e mondial alors qu'il était 42e
mondial en octobre 2022 la question sur
cette thématique peut-on être déçue de
son classement ATP nouveauté oui ou non
donc oui on peut être déçu oui on peut
être déçu mais c'est logique pas déçu
d'accord on fait un petit duel entre
Pierre et vous Philippe alors Philippe
c'est parti non je suis je suis pas déçu
des 72e mondial qu'il est en
2023 il a eu enfin pour l'instant c'est
que deux victoires dont une en Coupe
Davis en 2022 il a il a eu un titre de
final 22 victoires 19 défaites quand
même faut voir d'où il part c'est
surtout par rapport à ça et c'est pas
non moi je suis voilà je suis
pensé le tennis c'est malheureusement
c'est le c'est le tennis français je
veux dire c'est c'est
attristé parce que parce que voilà il y
a Roland-Garros qui va arriver je me
pose des questions donc c'est vrai que
il y a toujours peut-être quelqu'un qui
peut arriver mais je vois là il reste un
jeune à Miami c'est Alice je crois qui
reste mais qui va jouer contre en quart
de finale je vois c'est quand même déjà
pas mal mais je veux dire il y a plus de
bon comment il s'appelle ils ont voulu
revenir la compétition mais je veux dire
Gasquet tout ça c'est trop enfin je veux
dire c'est trop vieux c'est trop vieux
je veux dire non moi je suis inquiète
pas par rapport à lui mais par rapport
au tennis au tennis en plus lui erican
day il est arrivé tard sur le tard sur
le sur le tennis donc bon il a eu
universitaire
il avait réussi deux ou trois tournois à
suivre mais c'est pas les résultats que
que
son parcours voilà je vais vous le faire
alors il a gagné un titre en 2022 à
posenane il a fait deux finales donc
c'était en 2022 il a gagné un titre en
2021 à Istanbul en 2020 il a gagné deux
titres ses meilleurs parcours en Grand
Chelem c'est deuxième tour à l'Open
d'Australie en 2022 et deuxième tour en
2022 et 2021 à l'US Open et voilà ouais
non non non c'est son bilan
pour deux choses la première c'est que
au même titre que les Templiers des
longs cours sont notre équipe de sport
collectif un peu fétiche sur ce plateau
Arthur Riner c'est notre sportif
individuel un peu fétiche aussi sur ce
plateau on aime bien Sony c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais il y a ce côté Poulidor
chez chez notre Arthur bon c'est vrai si
c'est vrai chez Tony
et le deuxième point et et Philippe la
résumé c'est c'est le tennis français et
que malgré tout en fait on doit on doit
faire avec ce qu'on a dans le tennis
français pour pour ce qui me concerne je
pense que le tennis français dans son
panache s'est arrêté en 1983 avec Noah à
Roland-Garros
peut-être qui va arriver bientôt pour
gagner on lutte mais on lutte pour
s'accrocher à des résultats
en tournoi régulier ATP et en Grand
Chelem c'est même on chiale pour essayer
de trouver des résultats heureusement il
y a Caro Garcia qui a fait qui a fait
quelques étincelles là récemment dans le
tennis féminin qui est désigné
de rinderneche il a il a en fait il
était il est arrivé tard après avoir
cette carrière
aux États-Unis d'abord avant de revenir
en France et puis c'est c'est quelques
coups de panache effectivement en
Australie avec des avec des matchs dans
un contexte très très hostile en
Australie et finalement il tape en
australien sur le premier tour et puis
il passe il passe derrière donc là on y
croyait on y croyait en fait donc c'est
ça moi ma déception elle est là et le
fait qu'il se ise jusqu'au 42e 42e
jusqu'à la 42e place mondiale bon oui on
se contente de peu mais le tennis le
masculin français c'est ça donc moi ma
déception elle est là parce que on en
parle depuis quasiment son arrivée sur
le tennis professionnel c'est je ferai
un tout petit parallèle moins moins
glorieux par rapport à Mathilde gros qui
venait du basket qui vient en haut qui
vient au qui vient au vélo et qui a des
résultats là pour le coup bien bien
meilleur bien meilleur mais le Arthur on
l'attendait on l'attendait on en a parlé
on a été quand même assez prudent malgré
tout et il a eu quelques résultats au
départ il lui manque maintenant en plus
des titres que vous avez rappelé il lui
manque maintenant un vrai beau chemin en
Grand Chelem je parle même pas de Roland
Garros parce que ça je j'en rêve encore
la nuit d'un parcours d'un Français
à Roland Garros mais quand on quand on
voit en gros les que Richard Gasquet a
112 ans est encore capable de faire de
faire quelques résultats et dire que
c'est le meilleur français du moment
Gaëlle mon fils a 94 ans et demi et
capable aussi de faire des de faire des
coups
doyen de l'humanité
et qui vient juste de prendre sa
retraite voilà donc on fait on fait avec
ce qu'on a donc ma déception elle est là
parce que Arthur promettait et que c'est
un monde grecque ça
et que et que on aurait bien voulu qu'il
aille un petit peu plus loin et là il a
des sorties des radars et on peut on ne
peut que pleurer avec pleurer pour
l'instant il va revenir il va revenir
qui vous a convaincu est-ce que vous
restez campé sur vos positions ah oui
oui pour moi c'est c'est décevant mais
c'est décevant c'est décevant mais
c'est peut-être simplement la continuité
de la fin de saison 2022 voilà il a été
blessé pendant pendant une bonne période
il y a eu du mal à revenir
fin 2022 il était inexistant et c'est
vrai que là il a du mal à revenir alors
après il peut y avoir une une lumière
une étincelle qui qui peut qui peut tout
allumer et puis et puis sur six mois
faire une super fin de saison mais c'est
vrai que là aujourd'hui on est on est
mi-mars
sincèrement c'est clair que les Le Pen
d'Australie on attendait avec avec
impatience il avait passé un tour
l'année dernière il avait dû abandonner
sur blessure en 2022 donc là on se
disait allez c'est bon et puis bah non
non et donc comme dit comme dit Pierre
on est on est juste déçu déçu c'est tout
donc à lui de de nous redonner le
sourire quand on quand on regarde les
résultats tout simplement c'est tout
parce que on restera
il a déclaré forfait le dernier enfin il
a 4 ans il a abandonné le dernier match
il a beaucoup de problèmes physiques en
ce moment et je rappelle il est quand
même assez grand il fait plus d'un mètre
90 donc il a un physique un peu atypique
tous les tennisman aujourd'hui font plus
d'un mètre 80
et 1,90 c'est pas c'est pareil
Nadal et Djokovic se font moins d'un
mètre 90
mais oui depuis l'année 805 il y a pas
une grosse différence ça c'est le
gabarit d'un tennisman
85 c'est des beaux bébés on est d'accord
genre
mais je vais rajouter juste sur tout ce
qui a été dit parce que il y a pas mal
de choses simplement pour moi c'est un
sportif comme tous les autres on en a
peut-être aussi fait un grand sportif
qui n'est pas voilà après dans l'équipe
de France parce que non mais ça d'accord
et pas que nous mais on parle qu'on est
à la recherche de la pépite du tennis
français
qu'on cherche depuis très très longtemps
qu'on a pas et on s'aperçoit on
s'aperçoit quoi s'aperçoit que dès qu'il
y a un tennisman et qui brille un peu on
en fait de suite la vedette et le futur
grand joueur français qu'on attend tous
depuis 83 alors il a eu ben il a eu il a
eu il a eu sa sa période là où il
montait en flèche il est passé car il
est allé jusqu'à un deuxième place sur
mondiale mais mais voilà c'était un
sportif il a peut-être il a peut-être
atteint son maxi il va peut-être atteint
son maxi tout simplement il était même
surpris de ce niveau là
il était même un peu surpris d'en
arriver là ce qu'il voulait c'était
faire le mieux possible lui il est
arrivé 42e mondial on l'a dit il est
arrivé tard à ce niveau ce niveau
professionnel et international il est
arrivé tard il a il a bénéficié de bons
résultats au bon moment il a grimpé il
est jusqu'à la 42e maintenant je pense
que c'est c'est peut-être pas il a dit
lui-même c'est peut-être pas non plus
son objectif d'être d'être de faire
partie des 10 meilleurs mondiaux et
c'est peut-être aussi au niveau français
ça c'est bien français mais on en fait
de suite une grande star du tennis
français et au niveau mondial pour dire
ça y est on tient notre chef de fil
parce que on le cherche depuis 83 donc
je pense que ben il 16 sportif comme
tous et il est
agression il gagne pas donc il descend
c'est normal le gros souci on tennis
c'est logique je le rappelle il faut
avoir à peu près le même nombre de
points par rapport à l'année précédente
pour rester dans le dans le classement
bien cassé mais faut gagner un Grand
Chelem à Roland-Garros devra
techniquement gagner un nouveau Grand
Chelem à Roland-Garros pour garder le
même nombre de points c'est normal quand
même mais oui
c'est pas mal mais c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas le grand joueur français qu'on
attend c'est pas ça fait combien de
temps qu'on a pas eu un Français top 10
quoi
mon fils
je ne dis pas qu'on en a pas eu je dis
juste ça fait combien de temps parce que
en effet c'était régulier d'avoir un
français dans les 10 premiers du
classement ATP là
on a on a plus de résultats chez les
filles Ringer en étant 42e je me
souviens quand on avait un Français qui
était dans les 10 premiers ça voulait
dire qu'il y en avait d'autres qui qui
était entre la dixième place et la
cinquantième place là il était premier
Français 42e c'est on dit depuis tout à
l'heure c'est inquiétant
petit bilan quand même pour Arthur
rhinognech dans toute sa carrière 42
victoires pour 43 défaite voilà pour
pour faire pour situer la carrière
d'Arthur et notre chance c'est à peu
près voilà à peu près équivalent
équilibré on continuera en tout cas
c'est mieux que Tony ok effectivement
alors continuons évidemment à suivre
Arthur dans les prochains mois alors on
va maintenant parler d'un Capitana qui a
fait grand bruit celui de Killian Mbappé
le jour du Paris-Saint-Germain a été
choisi pour succéder à Hugo Lloris c'est
l'idée Deschamps qui a annoncé la
nouvelle au joueur depuis le camp de
base des Bleus à Clairefontaine dans les
Yvelines la question sur cette
thématique est-ce que c'est une bonne
idée monsieur
oui ou non votez
vous êtes partagé à deux rugbyman
partagés d'accord alors Jean pourquoi
il connaît rien au foot parce que
non pas du tout alors je suis partagé
pourquoi tout simplement parce que on va
pas remettre ici les qualités les
qualités sportives de Kylian MBP ça
c'est sûr maintenant
un très bon sportif ne fait pas
spécialement un bon capitaine voilà il y
a ça c'est prouvé dans tous les sports
c'est pas parce qu'il est exemplaire
fait exemplaire c'est peut-être pas le
terme parce que il est bon il a de la
réussite sur le terrain merci Yann il
est bon sur le terrain il a réussi sur
le terrain que c'est que ça va faire
obligatoirement un bon capitaine un
capitaine pour moi et en plus c'est
peut-être ça peut même gérer encore plus
loin ça peut même être néfaste pour lui
parce que le rôle de capitaine
quelquefois et ben ça ça prend le dessus
sur le côté technique et les
performances sportives du joueur qui est
capitaine donc pour moi ce joueur là
capitaine c'est alors c'est bien parce
que c'est le fer de lance de l'équipe de
France c'est le meilleur joueur c'est
tout ce que vous voulez mais c'est pour
ça que je suis partagé mais ça peut être
aussi le revers de la médaille en disant
mais est-ce que ce rôle de capitaine va
pas va pas le faire diminuer dans ses
performances sportives visiblement on va
dire que non mais
voilà sur le premier match mais pour moi
un capitaine n'est pas forcément le
meilleur joueur de l'équipe est-ce que
vous en étant coach vous avez vous
choisissez toujours le meilleur jour de
l'équipe ou justement
non en fait c'est pas que je choisis pas
je choisis le joueur qui va qui va alors
qui est qui est le plus
le plus méritant c'est à dire qu'il va
qui va vraiment c'est peut-être pas le
meilleur mais par contre il va donner
tout ce qu'il a sur le terrain et qui a
aussi un petit peu de charisme et qui
sait parler voilà pour moi ce que c'est
qu'un capitaine c'est à dire que il va
être autant avant pendant et après un
leader un leader naturel et quelqu'un
qui va être écouté par rapport sur le
terrain soit parce que c'est un
excellent joueur ça tombe sur un
excellent joueur tant mieux mais ça peut
être aussi quelqu'un qui est pas le
meilleur mais qui va tout donner qui va
montrer l'exemplarité qui va amener
l'équipe dans cette direction là et qui
va et qui va tirer le groupe vers le
haut en disant vous voyez regardez ce
que je fais avec il va pas le dire mais
les joueurs vont l’écouter parce qu'ils
vont voir à travers lui quelqu'un qui
donne tout sur un terrain de sport pour
moi c'est ça un capitaine c'est pas
spécialement un très grand joueur c'est
quelqu'un qui fédère qui parle bien qui
a du charisme et qui est présent avant
pendant et après
on va revenir sur sur Mbappé du coup je
rejoins beaucoup ce que j'en dis et je
trouve que ben quand on voit qu'il y a
NBA P c'est
justement quelqu'un qui a ses qualités
c'est à dire que la polémique avec
Griezmann qui dit que en effet il mérit
il aurait pu endosser le rôle et en
effet trois sélections avec l'équipe de
France je tiens le légitime pouvait
prétendre au rôle de capitaine on est on
est complètement d'accord mais
là ce que ce que Kylian Mbappé a fait
pour répondre et pour réconforter
Griezmann en lui disant ben ça change
rien à ton rôle dans l'équipe le fait
que tu ne sois pas capitaine j'ai trouvé
que il l'avait très bien géré et ensuite
moi je trouve que Kilian c'est quand
même un très bon communicant quand on le
voit en conférence de presse il est
quand même toujours juste dans ces dans
dans ce qu'il dit il a pas il a il a pas
autant sa langue dans sa poche ou la
langue il joue beaucoup moins le rôle de
langue de bois que ce que peut faire des
champs et je trouve que justement il
apporte un peu de un peu de fraîcheur et
après je trouve que par le biais de ces
qualités et de ses résultats il a ce
leadership naturel
et qui va faire que justement les le
reste de l'équipe va le suivre et
ensuite sur le premier match qu'il a
fait il a répondu de la meilleure
manière avec cette première avec cette
passe décisive qui fait à qui fait à
Griezmann au bout de deux minutes de
deux minutes de jeu c'était vraiment
franchement je trouve que ça a été ça a
été idéalement et la partition était
sans faute le deuxième match beaucoup
plus autorifique mais on pourra on
pourra en rediscuter très très
longuement c'est pas pour moi ce n'est
pas problématique Philippe Mbappé
capitaine ça vous séduit ouais moi ça me
ça me séduit parce que bon il y a
l'habitude d'avoir la pression que ce
soit au PSG la pression même ailleurs il
a la pression parce que au PSG tout
repose sur lui je veux dire en fin de
compte sur ces résultats sur s'il est
pas bon on dit bah de toute façon aussi
il est pas là PG ils vont perdre on se
repose que sur lui et il est pas trop
jeune non
24 ans il est pas il est parti il est
pas trop jeune c'est pas je pense qu'il
est il a été très bon conférence de
presse ça on peut pas le dire
en fin de compte par rapport à Loris
c'est pas il remplace pas quelqu'un
c'est une passation de pouvoir en fin de
compte tu vois Laurie c'était vraiment
c'est pas du tout le même c'était pas du
tout le même je veux dire ils sont
complètement différents et puis je me
dis ce qu'il a dit en plus
en équipe ou en collectif ou comme
disait Jean il faut pas qu'un seul
patron il faut des tôliers dans une
équipe et c'est ce qu'on dit enfin vous
vous dites bien en rugby il faut des
tauliers il y a un patron c'est sûr mais
c'est voilà il faut des tauliers à côté
et je pense que comment elle m'avait va
s'appuyer sur Griezmann Meignan il y en
a pas énormément il y en a plus il y en
a plus beaucoup maintenant mais je pense
qu'il va s'appuyer sur eux et on l'a vu
sur le match au Stade de France on l'a
vu il était dans la communication et sur
le terrain on voyait qu'il était
je sais pas il portait l'équipe il
contre les Pays-Bas pour les Pays-Bas et
même en Irlande et je trouve qu'il porte
l'équipe qu'on peut avoir un marqué il
portait l'équipe qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez à Pierre Chevalier est-ce que des
champs va pas un petit peu peut-être
contre sa nature parce qu'il aime bien
plutôt les capitaines un peu plus
discret en règle générale là Mbappé
c'est vrai qu'il a tendance à parler oui
mais je pense que je pense qu'en
l'occurrence Deschamps n'avaient pas le
choix n'avait pas le choix que que de le
nommer là où j'étais partagé c'est d'à
côté individualité exemplarité et de
l'autre côté le collectif et on a on a
un Mbappé qui qui est devenu
indispensable pour l'équipe de France
comme pour les comme pour le PSG par
exemple et en équipe de France on parle
de l'équipe de France
exemple ça ça prestation classe mondiale
en finale de Coupe du Monde et un
joueur qui par ses performances et ses
personnalités et devenu incontournables
je parle plus du PSG là je parle
vraiment que que de l'équipe de France
ce qui est vrai d'ailleurs au PSG et là
où là où moi je suis partagé c'est que
c'est que on a on a un joueur qui est
totalement exemplaire sur le terrain
parce que c'est il a des niveaux de
performance qui sont incroyables
c'est-à-dire que l'équipe de France sans
qu'il y a une n'est pas la même
je fais un tout petit parallèle en
remontant à aux années 2000 entre 2000
et 2010-2011 avec le Capitana Thierry
Dusautoir parce que ça ça m'inspire un
petit peu la même la même comparaison
avec des joueurs qui sont
incontournables exemplaires sur le
terrain qui font des presque qui
enchaînent les prestations comme des
perles et qui sont capables de de faire
tourner en fait le destin d'un match à
eux seuls et à côté de ça là où là où je
suis partagé c'est et c'est ce que ce
qui évoqué les gens c'est ce côté
personnalité est-ce que est-ce que la
personnalité qu'il y a Mbappe est
suffisamment universelle suffisamment
suffisamment fédératrice pour le
vestiaire les deux premiers matchs
semblent semblent prouver qu'a priori un
ça n'a pas d'incidence sur sa propre
performance puisqu'il en plane deux de
bonnes factures contre les Pays-Bas et
que il est quand même relativement actif
même s'il ne marque pas contre l'Irlande
et à côté de ça
je pense que c'est aussi dans l'ordre
des choses collectif sur la partie sur
la partie ordre des choses et de cycle
qui change Lloris sorti les vieux de la
vieille des mandandas aussi pour parler
des gardiens et puis Varane qui est
Varane qui finalement prend sa retraite
donc là en gros je pense que des champs
devaient absolument pas le choix d'avoir
une voix d'avoir un niveau d'avoir un
une exemplarité en l'occurrence par
Kylian Mbappé qui a 24 ans et qui a
prouvé maintes et maintes fois qu'il
n'avait pas la personnalité de son âge
qui est capable de parler qui est
capable de fédérer qui est capable de se
correr et d'emmener l'équipe de France
là où on l'a jamais là où on l'a jamais
imaginé et avec les avec l'euro et la
prochaine Coupe du monde en ligne de
mien voilà on continuera évidemment à le
suivre Kylian Mbappé avec ses
performances au PSG en tout cas jusqu'à
la fin de la saison apprendre c'est pas
pour pour le PSG et avec l'équipe de
France où il sera la le faire de lance
on va dire de cette équipe de France au
moins jusqu'à l'euro en tant que
capitaine en passe maintenant notre page
débat
on va maintenant faire parler des JO de
2024 on va parler des volontaires 45000
volontaires vont être mobilisés sur près
de 45 sites en Île-de-France et dans
toute la France pour se porter
volontaire il suffit d'avoir 18 ans au
1er janvier 2024 de parler français ou
anglais et d'être disponible au moins 10
jours sur la période des JO une
polémique a un peu gonflé ces derniers
temps sur le fait que des volontaires ne
sont ni payées ni indemnisés
l'organisation dit que cela existe
depuis 100 ans et que dans les grands
événements c'est toujours le cas la
question sur cette thématique des
volontaires non payées ni indemnisées
est-ce choquant oui ou non ou voter
on va faire un petit duel entre Jean et
Yann genre vous commencez alors vous ça
ne vous choque pas
mais ça me choque pas pour la simple
pour les raisons c'est comme disait
Coluche et la réponse est connue à la
question sont des volontaires sont des
volontaires pour ce qui est le plus
grand événement sportif de la planète
on va pas aller chercher on va pas aller
on les force à rien du tout il faudra
que le volontariat dans l'associatif
c'est de plus en plus rare c'est c'est
ce qui fait marcher les associations
donc je pense que pour cette événement
planétaire on ne peut que aller dans
cette dans ce
sens là puisque on est en plein dans
l'associatif volontaire associatif le
plus bel événement ils vont ils vont
avoir la chance quand même de participer
à cet événement qui a eu qui a eu lieu
la dernière fois il y a 100 ans ils vont
ils vont faire partie quand même
intégrante du du de l'organisation du
plus bel événement planétaire donc ça me
choque absolument pas que ces
volontaires là
le face à titre gracieux c'est le propre
de l'association en France voilà Yann
alors ensuite vous trancherez
déjà moi je suis complètement d'accord
avec avec toi Jean sur
la question c'est est-ce que je trouve
cela choquant c'est chaud je trouve cela
choquant et maintenant j'explique
pourquoi le budget des JO c'est
8,8 milliards d'euros d'accord
45000 bénévoles 100 € par jour
d'indemnité multiplier par
18 jours on l'a demandé on leur a
demandé 10 jours chacun 10 jours minimum
10 jours minimum je pars sur 18 parce
que je me dis qu'il faut un peu de
formation pour savoir etc donc on part
sur 18 jours ça fait un total de 81
millions d'euros ça fait 1% du budget
des de l'organisation des JO voilà c'est
juste pour ça que je trouve cela
choquant c'était une piscine à
Saint-Denis la moitié d'une piscine à
Saint-Denis c'est juste pour ça que je
trouve ça choquant c'est-à-dire que on
va utiliser de la ressource humaine
gratuite alors que cela ne représente
que 1% du budget global de
l'organisation c'est juste pour ça que
et la question et est-ce que je trouve
cela choquant et quand je prends ces
chiffres voilà pourquoi je trouve cela
choquant maintenant je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure en amont en effet dans le sport
et dans l'associatif le beaucoup
d'organisation
repose sur le bénévolat seulement moi
les chiffres les chiffres me choquent et
c'est juste ça et c'est seulement 1%
certes mais comme c'est la moitié de la
piscine de Saint-Denis donc dans une
dans une organisation et dans un cahier
des charges ça peut peut-être
représenter qu'un pour ça mais sur tout
ce qui est d'organisé mais je trouve que
c'est énorme je trouve que c'est énorme
1% du budget je vais à partir de ce
moment-là c'est quoi 1% là on dirait la
piscine après on me répond pas
la deuxième question c'est où va
l'argent vas-y pierre pierre
juste sur les arguments j'ajouterai à ce
que Dijon sur le fait que ce soit la
première la première le premier
événement sportif mondial en
l'occurrence qui a eu lieu au début du
20e siècle en France pour la dernière
fois il y avait plus de 100 ans je
rajouterais le terme amateur c'est à
dire que le l'olympisme c'est aussi
c'est aussi le monde le monde du sport
amateur
avant que certains passent
professionnelle on voit que ça se fait
pas toujours aisément comme Tony Yoka
par exemple dont on a parlé récemment
sur ces sur ce plateau et donc le on ne
force personne je reprends ça aussi dans
ce casier dans ce cas Dijon on le force
personne c'est sur la base du
volontariat du bénévolat dans l'esprit
de l'Olympique de Coubertin parce que
c'est autant au niveau sportif qu'au
niveau organisation l'essentiel cette
participer et que et que effectivement
sur 60 millions de Français un peu plus
de 65 millions français on ne force
personne à venir grossir les rangs
pendant 5 10 20 jours de de
l'organisation de
olympique de Paris 2024 et qu'en
l'occurrence on se rémunère à la passion
c'est la même chose pour tous les grands
événements sportifs mondiaux organisés
en France euro Coupe du Monde etc donc
tous les sports et donc là c'est c'est
l'occasion de prendre du temps en fait
juste prendre du temps de donner du
temps et d'être présent pendant 10 15
jours 20 jours
gracieusement mais parisien
très rapide c'est que c'est quand même
le propre de toute association sportive
aujourd'hui tout sport confondus où il y
a des bénévoles et ils ne font pas
pendant 18 jours ils le font toute la
saison à titre gracieux parce que c'est
leur passion et c'est de plus en plus
rare comme tu le disais et c'est le plus
rare mais c'est parce que c'est leur
passion et là on en trouve on en trouve
des tonnes
sur la Ryder Cup 2018 au Golf National
de 50 ans est-ce que vous habitez
indemnisés pas du tout pas du tout la
seule chose la seule chose qu'on peut
dire vraiment donc les organisateurs ont
raison sur les gros événements
pas un type alto Ryder Cup une tenue qui
a une tenue qui avait été gracieusement
offert au bénévole je pense que pour les
JO il y aura un t-shirt un truc comme ça
et donc non non et je l'ai fait et je
l'ai fait avec le plus grand plaisir et
j'en ai des souvenirs intéressants
Philippe apprends passera notre dernier
thématique les bénévoles ils sont pas
payés mais ça a pas de prix mais on dit
ça partout c'est vrai c'est vrai voilà
mais c'est exactement ça bon les
bénévoles déjà d'être comment faut
regarder que les candidatures il va
entre 120 et 170 candidatures
ils auront en plus mais vivre ça c'est
exceptionnel c'est une fois dans dans
leur vie ils vont avoir comme tu disais
tout à l'heure ils vont avoir un
équipement complet ils vont avoir les
transports gratuits certes en
Île-de-France pour se dépasser en
Île-de-France ils auront pas
l'hébergement
mais pour moi je veux dire moi je trouve
que c'est une belle une belle expérience
celui qui peut le vivre en tant que en
tant que comment bénévole je pense que
c'est c'est le c'est le summum je dirais
on va maintenant passer à notre dernière
thématique qui reste que 6 minutes donc
il faudra aller assez vite cette
thématique concerne le football si le FC
Versailles monte en Ligue 2 l'équipe
senior devra jouer à l'extérieur quand
il joueront à domicile en effet le stade
Momo n'est pas homologué pour des matchs
en Ligue 2 et le stade Jean-Bouin
dispose d'une pelouse synthétique
inadéquate il faudrait installer une
pelouse hybride dans l'enceinte du Stade
Français du coup deux options
s'offriraient au versaillé le stade
Marie Marvin au Mans ainsi que
Villeneuve-d'Ascq deux Boston qui sont
homologués pour la Ligue 2 je rappelle
déjà que cette année le FC Versailles a
dû s'expatrier du côté de Jean Bouin ils
ne peuvent pas jouer à Versailles car
leur terrain n'est pas homologué la
question sur cette thématique êtes-vous
pour ou contre un nouveau déménagement
du FC Versailles oui ou non
non partagé Jean
alors non non je suis partagé je suis
partagé pourquoi tout simplement parce
que
ils vont ils ont pas le choix si ils me
montrent ils ont pas le choix donc là
ils vont être dans la fête accomplie et
éventuellement donc là je viens de dire
je répète ils auront pas le choix ils
ont pas construit un stade et que là là
où je là là où ça va être compliqué
c'est où l'île où le Mans et là autant
j'en bois on reste quand même sur l'île
de France c'est accessible c'est on va
dire allez même si c'est pas Versailles
mais ça reste quand même jouable pour
les supporters pour pour pour l'identité
et l'entité du club
voilà tout à fait mais là si on commence
à partir au Mans ou à Lille là c'est
fini vers ça et personne son entité son
identité même et ça va être très
compliqué de pouvoir quasiment pour moi
impossible de pouvoir drainer des des
supporters fidèles dans des lieux aussi
donc là ça va être très compliqué pour
moi et pour eux malheureusement on a vu
le stade du Mans est quand même un très
beau stade il est beau mais c'est c'est
2h30 le manque quand même donc 2h30
autant pour Lille et ça veut dire que
les supporters vont jouer à l'extérieur
à tout le temps quoi ils joueront jamais
à domicile les joueurs les joueurs et
les supporters si on veut créer une
émulation au sein du club il faut les
supporters et les joueurs il y a plus de
points de repère non plus Yann qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez alors vous étiez pas
forcément d'accord avec Jean ah non j'ai
pas que je suis pas d'accord c'est que
en effet il ne faut pas que Versailles
aille soit délocaliser mais ils n'auront
pas le choix de toute façon voilà les
gens il a il a il a il a tout dit dès la
première phrase de toute façon ils n'ont
pas le choix mais il ne faut pas qu'il
soit délocalisé voilà c'est tout et
c'est donc quand on regarde le
classement
c'est pas fait hein parce que Concarneau
a un match de retard là ils sont
actuellement 4e
donc Martigues premier Red Star 2e
Concarneau et Versailles qui sont au
coude à coude et d'un quart qui est
juste derrière donc ça va être une
bataille à 5 pour monter mais voilà pour
déjà c'est pas fait et je pense que ce
serait un bien que cela ne se fasse pas
moi l'expérience veut que
tous les clubs qui se sont expatriés ils
sont tous redescendus donc ils ont mille
supporters au stade Jean-Bouin déjà
c'est pas loin il y a qu'une tribune de
commande de prise imagine à comment Oman
ou à Lille comment il y aura spectateurs
ceux qui vont venir ils vont venir pour
voir un match et encore s'ils font pas
des bons résultats il y aura personne
non moi je vois pas si il n'est pas créé
un match le lundi soir du Mont à la télé
il y a quoi il y a pas énormément de il
y a trois personnes enfin je veux dire
il y a pas beaucoup de personnes à Lille
allez la concurrence qui vont plus
référé aller voir le LOSC que
que non mais c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible je veux dire je souhaite
pas moi je pense que ce serait bien si
qui monte mais qui reste dans leur stade
et j'espère on voit bien que que leur
stade soit réaménagé qu'il puisse le
faire et là je pense que là ça créera
une émulation et ils sont proches bien
chevalier c'est ça
sur lequel il faut rebondir c'est qu'il
souhaitait c'est que bon on écarte le
fait que pour l'instant c'est pas fait
c'est loin d'être fait on a il y a
finalement un mois on en parlait un
petit peu plus sereinement de la montée
on dirait Versailles était en tête et la
tête et là pour le coup c'est ils sont
bien descendus après match nul et les
défaites et que là et que là c'est pas
fait ça mise à part le le problème
majeur c'est c'est finalement c'est
c'est de c'est de désolidariser l'équipe
de sa ville et que pour bien connaître
les problématiques de la ville de
Versailles c'est justement mettre le
paquet sur la possibilité de de
réhabiliter mon boron avec ses fameux
mal d'éclairage dont on parle de pile
départ en disant que c'est pour pouvoir
évoluer en Ligue 2 si j'y accède il faut
pouvoir jouer en nocturne notamment le
lundi soir et notamment à d'autres
périodes d'influence d'influence ou là
les spectateurs sont là est plutôt le
soir et donc il faut il faut justement
avoir de la lumière chez le Roi Soleil
une fois une fois que ça c'est dit
les en gros le reste c'est du piset
aller à Lille aller au mont c'est c'est
sportivement antinomique c'est à dire
que c'est effectivement on se on s'est
laissé le dernier là pour le coup de la
base des supporters qui ne vont
finalement pas plus à jambon que que
quelqu'un Versailles même donc donc déjà
on a on a un élément de réponse en
disant que cette saison en National
malgré les bons résultats de Versailles
jusqu'à maintenant il y a peu de monde
il y a peu de monde à jambon qui est à
qui est à 20 minutes de qui est à 20
minutes de Versailles imaginez deux
heures deux heures à Lille deux heures
et quart à Hautmont on se coupe de la
base donc on se couche de nos de nos
spectateurs
normalement c'est pas possible par
rapport
Louis XIV parce que je le rappelle on ne
peut pas jouer au stade mauboron enfin
en tout cas avec l'éclairage actuel
parce qu'on n'a pas le droit d'avoir de
source lumineuses depuis la chambre du
Roi Soleil du coup on ne peut pas jouer
avec ça mais après il y aura aussi
d'autres problématiques sûrement en
termes de place voilà il y aura pas
forcément assez de place pour pouvoir
accueillir des matchs de Ligue 2 aussi
donc
il pourrait y avoir des problèmes là
chaque match avec les ma d'éclairage qui
vont que d'avoir quatre Pékin au moment
où à Lille en suivant le dossier avec
attention en tout cas c'est déjà la fin
de cette émission on va terminer comme
d'habitude par une citation aujourd'hui
je vous propose une citation de Michael
Jordan peut-être le plus grand
basketteur de tous les temps certains
veulent que ça arrive d'autres
aimeraient que ça arrive et les autres
font que ça arrive je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
TV 78
[Musique]